mercredi 15 février l'humoriste Pierre
Palmade a été placée en garde à vue
suite à son application dans un accident
de voiture survenu vendredi dernier
plutôt dans la matinée à Clichy dans les
Hauts-de-Seine un homme a été interpellé
soupçonné d'être l'un des deux passagers
de la voiture du comédien en fuite
depuis l'accident le drame est survenu
vendredi 10 février vers 19h à hauteur
de Villiers-en-Bière en Seine-et-Marne
Pierre Palmade qui conduisait sous
l'emprise de la cocaïne et accompagnée
de deux jeunes gens est entrés en
collision avec un autre véhicule qui
arrivait en face à bord de cette voiture
se trouvait un homme avec son fils âgé
de 6 ans et sa belle-sœur enceinte
Pierre Palmade est aujourd'hui sortie du
coma ainsi que les trois occupants de
l'autre véhicule en revanche le bébé
annetre n'a pas survécu le garçon de 6
ans aurait la mâchoire fracturée et
serait défiguré le comédien avait pris
la route pour aller faire des courses
lorsqu'il a provoqué l'accident et on
sait désormais qu'il faisait la fête
depuis 24 heures dans sa résidence de
Dammarie-les-Lys en compagnie de quatre
jeunes gens il était sous l'emprise de
la cocaïne et des analyses
complémentaires ont confirmé que la
prise de était récente au moment de
l'accident une enquête ouverte pour
homicide et blessures involontaires
ayant entraîné une incapacité totale de
travail supérieur à 3 mois par
conducteur sous l'emprise de stupéfiant
a été confiée au commissariat de Melun
Val de Seine ce qu'attend la famille
aujourd'hui pour le dire très
concrètement et très clairement elle
attend que justice soit faite que la
justice soit rendue et qu'évidemment la
notoriété de Monsieur Palmade n'influ ni
d'un point de vue médiatique ni d'un
point de vue judiciaire mardi la sœur de
Pierre Palmade s'est exprimée auprès de
l'AFP il a honte et assumera toutes les
conséquences de ses actes l'idée d'avoir
détruit la vie de cette famille le
dévast il ne pense qu'à eux aussi vendre
que cela puisse paraître pierre leur
demande pardon du plus profond de son
âme le délit domicile involontaire peut
être puni de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 75000 euros d'amende mais cette peine
peut être alourdi jusqu'à septembre
prisonnements et 100000 euros d'amende
en cas de circonstances aggravante telle
que la conduite sous stup la résidence
secondaire du comédien à sélier en bière
a été perquisitionné samedi dernier
aucune cocaïne n'a été saisie
l'humoriste avait déjà été condamné en
1995 pour consommation de cocaïne en
2019 il avait été placé en garde à vue
pour usage et acquisition de stupéfiant
après avoir été faussement accusé de
viol cette même année Pierre Palmade
confiait je suis passé à ça de mourir et
promettait de sa sagir selon ses proches
il se soignait avec beaucoup de sérieux
pour se débarrasser de ses addictions